okay so the other day I uploaded a video
about that 88 YouTuber that made like a
satirical Japanese convenience store
haul video and I realized after
uploading that video that there was
something else I had to get off my chest
not just about that YouTuber but about
let's be frank most foreigners living in
Japan and this is that the overwhelming
majority of foreigners living in Japan
aren't making the cut like they don't
act Japanese enough if you're living in
Japan you're not a tourist you're a
resident and being a resident comes with
certain responsibilities like learning
the language like have you ever noticed
that people that speak Japanese
literally never complain about Japan
it's always the foreigners that don't
speak any Japanese that are complaining
right but if you're living in Japan like
me you need to be speaking Japanese okay
like all the time foreigners if you're
living in Japan you need to be speaking
Japanese
what no I'm shooting a video and I need
you to subtitle it for me later
okay sorry like do you not see the irony
here
the other day I was having a
conversation with my friend
um just one of my friends it was a real
conversation but he was complaining
about how hard it is to learn Japanese
and how Japanese people don't speak
English good enough and I was like toes
in to show me Hong Jin Takara and
because I know a lot of people watching
don't speak Japanese perfectly yet that
means well obviously because they're
Japanese like why do they need to meet
your standards right and this actually
leads me to the final point of this
video and the final point is that
and the final point is that if you can't
be bothered to learn Japanese or do as
the Japanese do then you're just being a
nuisance and you should go home like
Japan will be fine without you the
Japanese economy is
well I mean the yen is it'll rebound
like these are just growing pains it'll
rebound let's be real and um I know that
there are some like so-called analysts
that have said
um Japanese companies can't find enough
young people but it's like have you ever
been to Shibuya or Harajuku there are
young people everywhere there are only
young people but just for the sake of
argument I know we can we can play
akama's Advocate and uh pretend that
these so-called analysts are correct
think about things from the perspective
of a Japanese company do you want
someone that can I don't know code but
doesn't speak perfect Japanese or
someone that can't code but speaks
perfect Japanese and we all know the
answer to that question because again
these are Japanese companies they don't
just have people that can explain things
in English you know it's not about again
whether or not they're meeting your
standards it's about what's good for
them this is why again if you're a
foreigner the most important thing is to
get perfect nihongo
sorry I did it again uh for those that
don't know nihongo